[Musik]
größer ulrich weigelt er ist der
bundesvorsitzende vom deutschen
hausärzteverband mit ihm wollen wir
sprechen über die impfstrategie bei den
hausärzten grüße sie unter herbei gilt
geht ihnen das jetzt zu langsam mit dem
impfen bei den hausärzten oder sind sie
damit einverstanden dass es mitte april
los geht also es geht mir insgesamt so
langsam mit dem impfen und wir wir sind
hinterher
wir haben leisten uns den luxus 4
millionen impfdosen in kühlschränken
lagern zu lassen um irgendwie die
impfzentren am laufen zu halten anstatt
pragmatisch und schnell und flexibel
dafür zu sorgen dass wir in kurzer zeit
möglichst viele menschen impfen
das ziel scheint völlig aus dem auge
verloren zu sein stattdessen diskutieren
wir ob in der reihenfolge die gruppe 1
truppe zwei gruppe 3 irgendjemand
vorgezogen oder zu früh dran wäre oder
noch nicht dran wer also es ist
irgendwie ein bisschen kafkaesk
inzwischen ist das der deutsche hans
schimmel der da wieder schimmelt dem
volksmund nach oder gibt es auch zwingen
der juristische gründe weshalb die
länder jetzt noch zeit brauchen also
dass die länder noch zeit brauchen und
dass sich ministerpräsidenten treffen
müssen um über die verteilung von
impfstoffen zwischen hausärztlichen
praxen und impfzentren zu beraten
das ist doch kaum noch mit einem
gesunden menschenverstand verstand
nachzuvollziehen es ist kein problem
tatsächlich hausärztliche praxen mit
impfstoff zu beliefern
das kann über die impfzentren sein das
kann wir hassen sagt über die apotheken
die verkaufen und es wäre sehr einfach
und pragmatisch lösbar die hausärzte
bestellen für ihre patienten für die
woche eine bestimmte menge impfstoff ist
der vorhanden wird er geliefert ist der
nicht komplett vorhanden wird etwas
weniger geliefert und wir werden das mit
dem patienten besprechen und woran hakt
ihrer ansicht nach oder wo wir der
gordische knoten zu lösen
in der der gordische knoten wer zu lösen
indem man einfach jetzt anfängt sagt ja
kommen hausärzte lasst uns gucken wie
können wir das am besten hinbekommen
anstatt in irgendwelchen runden die es
auch im grundgesetz gar nicht gibt zu
sitzen und zu überlegen wie man
irgendetwas machen kann also wir haben
den eindruck dass die impfzentren
eingerichtet waren ursprünglich weil der
impfstoff auf minus 70 grad gekühlt
werden musste und das können wir in den
praxen nicht dass diese impfzentren eine
ganz große bedeutung haben die menschen
wollen aber gar nicht unbedingt in
impfzentren und schon gar nicht auf dem
land 100 kilometer reisen sondern sie
wollen von ihren hausärzten hausärzten
geimpft werden sie fragen uns jeden tag
und ich hätte gerne einen sachlich
vernünftigen grund gehört weswegen man
das nicht einfach macht man kann ja
meinetwegen die impfzentren noch eine
weile behalten
aber jetzt heißt es die müssen bis
september bleiben und da fragt man sich
auch was das eigentlich für gründe an
diesen impfzentren dermaßen start
festzuhalten
jetzt ist es ja so wenn ich beim
hausarzt anrufen ist es früher bleiben
sie weg damit sich die hausarztpraxis
anstecken jetzt sagen alle hausärzte
kommen sie her lassen sich impfen
da muss man natürlich nachhaken ist da
auch ein großes geschäft mitzumachen
oder wieso plötzlich dieser umschwung
ja ich weiß nicht das geschäft ist glaub
ich eher moment woanders glaube nicht
dass das impfen bei hausärzten das große
geschäft ist impfen ist eine routine
aufgabe einer routinetätigkeiten
hausärztlichen praxis und jetzt muss man
vielleicht auch differenzieren wir haben
gesagt am anfang der pandemie diejenigen
die nicht krank sind die nicht die
hausärzte hilfe benötigen unbedingt die
sollen vielleicht gucken dass sie erst
mal anrufen und vielleicht dass man auch
mal einen infekt so übersteht
wir haben jetzt vielleicht eher das
gegenteil wir brauchen manchmal
überredungskunst zu sagen dann diabetes
lieber patient oder die patientin ist
doch beobachtungs bedürftig musste man
kommt und ich glaube auch dass wir eine
eine gute möglichkeit haben die
impfungen in den hausärztlichen alltag
zu integrieren das schaffen wir
bei den wällen die wir bei der
grippeimpfung jährlich haben ja auch
also es gibt keinen sachlichen grund es
gibt verdächtigungen und es gibt
vermutungen aber es gibt keinen grund
und willi pilot
projekte sehen die funktionieren
hervorragend ob das jetzt in brandenburg
ist in mecklenburg vorpommern und ich
glaube das zeigt dass wir jetzt
pilotprojekte brauchen um zu prüfen ob
hausärzte impfen können die ist glaube
ich schon ein paar jahrhunderte vorbei
wir werden dann ihre vorgehensweise wenn
sie wenn ich mich impfen lassen würde
würden sie sagen wie frau merkel ich
warte bis ich an der reihenfolge bin
oder würde ich zum telefon greifen 116
117 anrufen und sagen hier
ich kann in zwei stunden vorbei kommen
wenn ihr heute abend noch was im schrank
stehen hat weil patient xy nicht
erschienen ja das ist die diskussion die
kann man stundenlang führen ich glaube
erst mal muss man zusehen dass man die
menschen geimpft werden und natürlich
gehen wir davon aus und das ist ja auch
das was wir machen
wir sehen zu dass wir die menschen im
handy ist brauche
ob wir jetzt in 74 jährigen
modellathleten vorziehen müssen vor
einem 69-jährigen kranken mit diabetes
hochdruck und übergewicht das kann man
sich natürlich dann auch gerne noch mal
überlegen aber in der regel werden wir
das so machen und wenn tatsächlich
nichts anderes ist außer dass der
impfstoff übrige soll man erwischt
niemand dann ist es egal wen man im team
mal ein impfstoff wegwirft muss man doch
vielleicht immer auch von einer starren
gnadenlosen regelung abweichen können
okay aber jetzt steht der hausarzt da
und dann hat er den 74 jährigen
modellathleten dann hat er hier den
50-jährigen phoenix moderator der sagt
er ich muss morgen arbeiten entscheidet
dass dann der hausarzt wenn wir die
spritze gibt
wer soll das denn entscheiden das hat es
dem finder ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
fragen oder oder wie soll das sein also
ist doch klar dass wir sozusagen nach
der nach der leitlinie vorgehen die wir
haben aber die frage ist ob man eine
leitlinie in die narren gnadenloser
starre verfolgen muss und sagt
hauptsache wir haben auf jeden fall hier
keinen fehler in der reihenfolge gemacht
selbst in dem stoff wegwerfen
das ist doch irre geht es denn dann wenn
die haushalte sondern auch die
betriebsärztliche stehen ja auch noch
hand in hand daneben impfen können
wirklich rasant hoch mit den impfungen
wir können sagen in drei vier monaten
sind wir dann wirklich durchgeimpft als
deutschland
wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass weder
die hausärzte noch die betriebsärzte
dran schuld sind dass wir zu wenig
impfstoff haben weil wir jetzt davon gar
nicht anfangen
in der tat ist es so dass wenn die
hausärzte und ich glaube auch dass es in
den betrieben vernünftig ist dort zu
impfen
dann gemeinsam impfen dann wird auf
jeden fall erreicht werden dass nicht
vier millionen impfdosen ungenutzt in
kühlschränken liegen um zu gucken ob in
impfzentren vielleicht irgendwann noch
mal jemand kommt also das ist doch
unmöglich in der jetzigen situation und
dafür können wir sorgen das glaube ich
das gilt für die hausärzte wie auch für
betriebsärztin betrieben die das machen
und das heißt im moment sind wir doch in
einer situation wo wir zu sehen müssen
dass wir das was wir bekommen auch so
schnell wie möglich impfen können jetzt
hören wir die zahlen gehen hoch und wir
sitzen da und machen eine runde nach der
anderen und überlegen uns wo wir
vielleicht noch mal impfstoffe verteilen
können also das geht gar nicht
ulrich weigelt mit deutlichen worten er
ist der bundesvorsitzende der deutschen
hausärzte des deutschen
hausärzteverbandes und sagt nicht reden
sondern machen dankeschön einen schönen
tag
vielen dank